hello there and welcome to multi screen
multitasking the latest app from any QR
productions that's me
Adamson it's key so basically if you've
ever wanted your Android to be able to
do more and if you ever wanted to be
able to multitask on it as there was a
whole PC you're gonna love this app
because basically I personally wanted my
Android to ever do more things that I
could work on the go browse multiple
websites at once and generally use my
Android more like a PC I don't like the
kind of restrictions you often get from
mobile devices and so I created this for
myself well then release it to the store
and it's been quite a big success so
thankfully you like it and I'll show you
what it can do now so basically I wanted
to be able to launch as many different
things in little Windows as possible
unfortunately this can't run the apps
that are installed on your device that's
not possible due to the way that Android
works however what I've tried to create
here is the next best thing so basically
I've programmed lots of small apps into
one larger app and got those little
functions to run inside movable and
resizable windows so for instance here
you have your browser you move around
the screen and do essentially anything
you would normally do with a browser
it's got a list of favorites
it's got options and settings stop
refresh forwards backwards all the
normal stuff that you might expect basis
I drag to the side of the screen here
and it clips on to that edge of the
screen that then makes it much more
useful to use another browser or two
more browsers you can use them on top of
each other there's no problem with that
like so so why would you want to be able
to use two browsers at once browsers it
just tip of the iceberg by the way most
are with browsers well one reason you
might want to is so that you can go to
Facebook you might want to speak to your
friend on facebook chat one at the same
time reading IGN which is probably my
favorite eg website
this way I could be chatting to a friend
whilst at the same time reading the
latest news about the new Superman film
etc which some people might want to do
alternatively you can also watch YouTube
more screen multitasking supports video
also has a movie player for watching
your mpegs but I'll actually have any on
my device at the moment so let's find
something to watch have a look at this
Sonic Colors we walk through measures
we're playing music and watching a video
at the same time else can you do that
move that around to everyone with it or
if you want it to be full screen double
tap or go to full screen like say but if
you want to bring something from behind
back to the front it's really annoying
isn't it
so let's pause that music let's bring it
to the front yes so you hold on the icon
pops up to the front like this you
control that lets pause that that's
annoying too but if this still isn't
enough space for you settings hide of
show bottom bar and there you go you're
now using the full size of your screen
so you can use it as a multi screen
multitasking thing or you can just use
it as a regular browser whatever you
like and you can use that like that and
you can drag whatever you want this
could be a facebook chat for instance
and you can drag it around over the top
of whatever you're doing here so it's
close that for a bit and let's look at
some of the other stuff notice how these
windows change shape because i've to
accommodate the larger screen size now
show the bond bar again let's put the
music back on I start at the beginning
so what else do we have here well for
instance we have a text editor why might
you want to have a text editor open at
the same time as your browser well for
instance you can be reading here looking
or whatever news you want or go to
Wikipedia which I've bookmarked
and you can write about Wikipedia so
this way when you're researching a topic
for an essay or for work you don't have
to keep switching in between apps you
can do it all in one you can copy and
paste obviously copy that paste it into
here
how much more convenient is that and
this has got an email function so if you
wanted to copy and share something that
way you can just copy it paste it and
then send the email straight from your
text editor which i think is kind of
useful it's got a word count feature
which is something you don't normally
have on many word processors and things
there's 33 words 212 characters I think
it's pretty useful go into my website
now I'm going to show you something else
the website has a huge background and I
have a slow internet connection others
later okay good
this websites also my this app I mean is
rather quite useful for web designs as
well I'll show you why because here you
have a function allows you to view the
source of the webpage you're on so there
you go that's the source of the bio
matrix on my website so if I wanted I
could edit that and then I could save it
as an HTML file on my device and edit it
from there soon my apps gonna support
FTP so you'll be able to edit files
directly online using the text editor
and preview them on here because that's
something else this can do yes new
document obviously this works very well
at the mouse and keyboard but there's
much before and have that I wanted to
show it to you like this this is the
this is a HTML for those that don't know
that's the bold tag and I'm just showing
you this because it's useful for
developers hello now open his web page
suppose the other thing opens web page
and there you go nice it's abled it in a
new browser for interrupted what I'm
doing here
and they have it that's very handy if
you obviously you want to edit lots of
different websites and things specialist
doesn't stop so this is for fun and it's
for productive uses sorts of we've got
we've also got the file manager here the
file manager is useful for all kinds of
things you can look at images you can
delete obviously copy/paste search just
as any other file manager you've got
your icons to show you what each thing
does and if you click on it they'll open
it with big correct we do have video
actually I lied so you click a video I
do not know what that is opens
automatically in the video player oh
okay let's just close that goodbye
that's awkward okay yeah mmm stop the
music again you did not see anything
anyway you can get down pops up see just
what is in this folder okay so if you've
got this image here long click you get a
preview of the image you can cut the
link copy rename or set as background
it's not particularly attractive
background but let's set it anyways so
you can see there's also settings here
so you can make the app exactly the way
you want it if you don't like these bars
if you think they're ugly as some people
have said which is hurtful because I
made them myself
go to settings you can change the file
size as well to make them bigger or
smaller change the bar color make it a
nice light blue it's quite nice theme
actually isn't it so notice we've
completely changed the look of this app
or something else you can do and in the
future I'm going to be introducing
shortcuts down the side here so you
really can use it for windows thing now
what's this here what's this icon that's
PDF which we also have support for and
this app
double tap again and it goes in
minimizes so there's that PDF click that
it will remind you last page we haven't
got anywhere so the last paper is zero
and you can read PDF so you can read
your ebooks move them around the screen
so you want to be reading an e-book
whilst at the same time listening to
music or watching a video that's
something you can do with my screen
multitasking again pretty handy you've
got zooming in skipped a page open
obviously and these icons represent the
draw pad which is another app on here
click that this is Frazier's house
there's a crane so it's opened in my
draw pad I can draw on it as you might
expect change my pen color all kinds of
fun stuff well I can stare clearly to
start a new drawing enjoy another smiley
face which is like literally all I draw
the reason this might be useful is say
you're an artist and you want to copy an
image from your browser say I want to
get a picture of Fred Flintstone you can
do that on there
you've also got your rubber and do
change your pen size all those kinds of
things that you expect yet again another
handy feature is a map so on the map
find out where you are see the satellite
now if your friend was asking for
directions on how to get to your house
or kind of just shed my addresses the
whole world is closed that as well just
going well say your friend will turn out
to get to your house you could open up
Yucatec some directions email them
directions on the phone version you can
also actually
texts and you're gonna be I'll answer
the phone so think I think I've shown
you the very basics of this app there's
a lot more you can do with it and really
it's however you want it people have
surprised me with the uses they found
for it
one guy was using it for karaoke so he
could listen to the music and read the
lyrics at the same time you know not the
usage that I had a visit for it but like
that's just the thing it'll liberate the
way you use your device and can also
view whatever app you have in the
background by doing a transparent
background I have another home screen in
the background so there's Ana Seamus but
Sir so if you've got widgets on your
home screen you can look at things like
the time etc but yeah so that's the
basics of this app I'm gonna be bringing
a lot more to it and stay tuned because
I'm bringing a desktop launcher in this
style there's got a lot of cool features
it's very different and that's gonna be
on Kickstarter so if you're interested
check out my website and the link so
you'll get all the latest information
and thanks checking it out I hope you
enjoy the app and if you do please leave
a positive review because the more you
help me to get exposure for it the more
I'll be able to update it and I've got
lots of exciting new fans in the future
I can say FDP something's coming soon
links to favorites and that a desktop
launcher that should change the way you
use your device so thank you very much
for watching I hope you find this
interesting and please do check out the
app and just to demonstrate quickly this
is multi screen multitasking in portrait
mode on a phone as you can see it works
just as well everything scales nicely to
the smaller device versus a whopping
phone and have a Galaxy Note which I
have a modified heavily and you have all
the same functions which works exactly
the same except you also have messaging
there's my messages and if you type a
message in here you can send it to
everyone you have any message from
everybody as well as a list of you
contacts and you can send it to everyone
so they go if you want the phone version
look the mozzies be multitasking if you
want the tablet version look the multi
screen multitasking THD in the future
those texts are going to pop up over the
top of whatever you're doing say look
force to that and thanks again for
watching and look forced to seeing you
on those positive Playstore reviews
adios